We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P.
We got a voicemail from the Egemen. He believes
that the so-called concept of freedom of religion
is bogus because it doesn't apply to all religions
equally. Let's let the egg man say it himself.
Like only he can say, hey, Dave and Pat, I
think freedom of religion is overrated. No,
I think freedom of religion shouldn't be
a thing anymore. It's complete bullshit.
It's totally subjective. And it's a ban on full
face coverings in Switzerland is 100 percent a
good thing. Sorry, guys, but I'm totally for it.
You shouldn't be able to cover your entire face
in public. It's a safety problem in our country
and any country. Yeah, you can wear a mask for
health reasons. Of course. Here's the deal,
guys. People are using freedom of religion,
do the most insane things. And it's not that
they're doing the same thing. They're using
other people to do it. Same thing, a.k.a.
Spaghetti Monster Satanism. I have a religion
that is not acknowledged by this country or by
the world. And I don't get freedom of religion.
I smoke marijuana for my
reasons. It harms no one right.
Illegal where I live. How come so people can cover
their entire face or do horrible things in the
name of their religion? I can't smoke a bowl when
I come home to bring my prayers up to God because
that's what my culture tells me. Freedom of
religion is freaking stupid. We have to stop it.
It's going to cause tons more problems in
the future on this planet. Shallow brother.
All right, so there is the egg man shot out of
a cannon with a principled and defiant speech
supporting the face covering ban in Switzerland,
which we discussed yesterday on the bonus show.
All right. On today's bonus show, we will talk
about the fallout from the Harry and Meghan
interview. There's a really interesting media
story there. We will talk about the latest in
the George Floyd case, which is now going to be
delayed. And we will talk about a risk factor
for covid not getting that much attention, but it
correlates with 78 percent of those hospitalized.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Get instant access to the bonus show by
getting a membership at join Pakman Dotcom.
That's option number one or becoming a patron
at Patreon Dotcom David Pakman show. That
is option number two. I will see you then.